d'abord je félicite mon adversaire qui a
gagné je suis heureux pour lui un peu
moins pour la circonscription évidemment
qui n'aura pas un député dans la
majorité qui aura donc moins de jeu les
dix pendant la campagne mais ça n'a sans
doute pas été entendu - - influence
voilà c'est un petit peu des aspects
très positifs dans ce résultat je suis
devant
dans l'eau soit morvan en territoire où
je suis élue je travaille ou sans doute
je suis le plus le plus connu donc à une
vraie reconnaissance il est aussi
originaire de ce territoire est élu dans
ce territoire et dans ce territoire je
suis devant dans les cantons de montbard
venarey très largement je remercie les
électeurs de ma commune et du canton je
vais presque 68 % à venarey les laumes
donc c'est évidemment une reconnaissance
locale
devant le canton de sombernon
17 voix je crois moins de 20 voix dans
le canton de semur donc on est à égalité
et il va y avoir
40 voire en savoie a basculé dans le
canton de précy-sous-thil donc à part
vitaux et saulieu qui continuent à voter
assez majoritairement pour lui sur l'eau
soit morvan le résultat est très
satisfaisant mais mais ce qui compte
c'est le résultat final j'ai perdu
dont acte